call of the wild he has felt it he also
really speak he would also like you to
know the thumbnail of this videos it's
not like they you were your sister
there's no getting her on this cameras
she hates it more than he does we've
prattle done enough let's get to the
review so call of the wild is a new
movie starring Harrison Ford kind of
well he's all the human beings in this
movie are a supporting character which
makes sense I mean of all the animals in
the world like human beings that they're
clearly they're clearly the worst ones
absolutely the least likeable ones point
is this book was published in 1903 takes
place in the late 1800s during the Yukon
Gold Rush which kind of has something to
do with the movie as far as Buck's
concerned the movie actually stars a dog
named buck a very cgi dog named buck you
always know that you know the movie
starts out you're like that's the CGI
dog then the movie continues on you're
like that's still a CGI dog at no point
did I ever feel like bitten oh that's
dog maybe miss the days when people
actually use real dogs to do real dog
things as real dogs and movies and again
what are you gonna do have a real dog
hang out with real wolves probably not
so CGI dog it is it's like War Horse you
know like this animal has a few
different masters a few different owners
and just tracks the animal throughout
some owners are cool some are not summer
Harrison Ford which he was going the
movie but you feel like the Harrison
Ford buck dynamic is it's the point of
this movie when they're hanging out in a
place called the uncanny valley it's not
really called that oh really they're in
the middle of nowhere in that Yukon is a
gorgeous place you tube dries up and one
day it will be gone you might find me
there but as you get to the dynamic of
Harrison Ford and Buck the dog in this
movie which does feel like the point of
this movie it's another way of saying
the first hour of this movie is set up
for the first hour of this hour and a
half long movie the world bird yes I'm
still quoting John Locke from lost cos
is still relevant not about the
destination Jack it's about the journey
he's right in a world where it is about
the journey it's all important but still
for that last chunk they have Harrison
Ford so that's the point of the movie
because when you have Harrison for
you market the [ __ ] out of that no
probably didn't help but kept seeing
buck as a computer-animated dog because
buck acts like an animated dog he kind
of acted like a cartoon dog which is a
way of saying he acted more human than
dogs generally act like Harrison Ford's
just hitting the bottle getting drunk
trying to forget his problems buck who
shouldn't really know what he's doing is
like alcohol takes the bottle buries it
that's the devil's water mo you've done
that before like Beethoven you know and
David Duchovny is like we're talking
trash about the kids and Beethoven it's
like things like that work for movies
like Beethoven cuz that's what they're
going forward I didn't feel like the
call of the wild was going for that only
it kind of did that but on the other
hand you kind of have to do that with
the movie like this because bucks the
main character he kind of has to act
human enough you have a dog that like if
danger was the main character in a movie
the movie would simply be throw the ball
towards the bottom of the ball throw the
ball throw the ball and for the most
part this movie's fine it's a fine movie
it's a sweet movie you really get the
feeling they were like how many dog
lovers and dog owners are there out
there alright we're gonna we're gonna
hit them with the fields cuz that's what
this movie's gonna do yes that again is
the point because you can't deny it you
know I'm watching the movie like Oh
gypsy in danger but this movie really
does feel like one of those movies that
was made in the 90s based off of old
literature that they show in elementary
schools after the teacher reads the book
to the students there's a part of me
disliked do Studios do that on purpose
do they sell them to school districts
and make a profit that way I don't know
but I get the feeling your kids will
watch this movie in class after the
teacher reads the book to the class in
this movie your basic mustache twirling
villain he's like someone took the weird
science formula and poured it over an
art cell of snidely whiplash from Dudley
do-right who came to life I was like
yeah where is the gold
and that guy very ridiculous I didn't
need I mean because the story needs him
in some way that was like I'm fine with
Harrison Ford and buck hanging out let's
just let's go back there because I'm
happy there and that's basically the
movie is it a sweet movie yeah do you
like buck the dog even though the entire
movie are like CGI dog games still
written form CGI characters they're
people - do we need to watch the movie
again not really but if you know you
want to go back to when your parents
took you to iron will in the movie
theater so you want to take your kids to
a movie and you have
since Sonic the Hedgehog yet which
really it's nothing like iron well
pointers family movie if you want a new
one this weekend it's a fine time no
alcohol required matinee price
asterisks I put in there sometimes for
the sake of it there so call of the wild
have you seen it why did you think about
it or what's your favorite 90s movie
baby stuff literature whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]